how does it feel to be here for a
branches during Croatia it feels really
good to be to be back here always have a
good feeling coming to this our group
and Croatia so I'm good to go yeah
Zagreb is one of my favorite cities and
I always feel very comfortable here
everything about this tournament is
amazing like everything is professional
so I'm very happy to be back
it's a fantastic feeling I've been in a
I've played in granchester in back in 21
it was amazing so I'm very hard very
happy to be here again
uh this is my third year so now it's
becoming traditional and I'm every year
I'm looking forward to it it's one of my
favorite tournaments and the strongest
one as well
with the toughest opposition
to meet so I'm always always
being optimistic and I'm trying to to
make it to to be better than the last
year yeah it's uh it's always been my
dream to play in the granchester and
that's my debut so I'm really looking
forward to it yeah everything in Zagreb
is perfect so far hopefully yeah have a
very good
one of my favorite countries to to visit
and
probably one of my favorite events to
play and yeah probably didn't believe so
it's not too
too much prep yeah not too much tension
just just have fun so looking forward
I'm very happy to be in Zagreb again I
enjoyed my visit two years back
I mean two years back so it was very
very special because it was my
first tournament during the pandemic and
I could literally Escape here and I
spent a whole month here
but this time it's shorter but still
very happy to come back I have lots of
friends I've been catching up last few
days and looking forward to that and
also hopefully a good tournament yeah it
feels feels good it's been four years
since I've been here last year I played
in Poland and 2019 we were playing
classical chess
so it's going to be a bit different but
I'm also very motivated especially since
at the moment it's going well in the in
the franchise tour for me and so
hopefully I'll keep that up oh it feels
very nice this is actually my first time
being in Sacramento overall and yeah
I've been to Croatia and even played
some just in Croatia but it was like
another lifetime so yeah it feels very
interesting and I think Croatia being
you know part of this former yoga
slavian countries I think chess is very
well regarded
still and I'm looking forward yeah it's
very nice I had played once before two
years ago exactly here I mean I was
saying here in very hot for Western in
Zagreb but I sort of forgot about it to
be honest and now when I'm back it's
nice you know because like memory comes
back and um
yeah it was the last time for sure I
mean it was nice time
there so I hope this family will be even
better
thank you